[Music]
Robin Hood sees released this week and
unfortunately it's another huge turd for
the character I don't know why they
can't get their Nottingham native right
but it seems like every attempt since
the Kevin Costner version has been
really disappointing it's baffling that
Studios constantly try and reintroduce
the character for modern audiences but a
guess because he's out of copyright they
just see him as an easy cash grab as of
this review the movie is currently
sitting at 14% on Rotten Tomatoes and
whilst I never really put too much
weight into the website there's a clear
indicator here that it's not a good film
my biggest problem with the movie is
that it just feels like a mishmash of
things that you've seen done better a
thousand times before Robin Hood not
only steals from the rich but also
steals from bigger and better movies
which leaves this feeling very hollow
there are shades of Batman Guy Ritchie
and more in there but none of the
elements in this movie match the pieces
that they are derivative of to me Robin
Hood should be shot on locations and set
but the green-screen here is so heavy
that it massively takes you out of the
film there's no real weight to the work
and this feels like a sequel to
Assassin's Creed but for all the worst
reasons everything feels too clean and
crisp to really feel believable as a
landmark clothes streets and every
element of this film is immaculate and
it really Rob's the film of an undertone
of authenticity I'm not the only one who
has this criticism either and in their
review the New York Post said this isn't
the first time somebody has tried to
probe the dark recesses of this should
be charming action story the 2010 film
with Russell Crowe did it too but at
least that movie tried to approximate
the time period in director Otto
Bathurst snoo hood nottingham looks like
a roman fortress where everybody shops
at Tsar
it feels more like Robin hoodie and
Robin Hood and it's clearly just been
written by committee in order to appease
as many people as possible
Entertainment Weekly's Maureen Lee lenka
called Robin Hood a humorless heist
movie with no heart she stated that in
action sequences director Otto batters
picks up the shooting style perfected by
Guy Ritchie the artfully calibrated mix
of slow motion and hyper speed in a
poletik rush of violence Ritchie has
used a technique to comedic and
adventurous effect in the Sherlock
Holmes films but at this point the trick
feels stale that hearse approach is
derivative and lacks a narrative purpose
that has made the aesthetic shine in of
the context and I wholeheartedly agree
the movie just fails to deliver on every
level stylistically and feels like it's
missing its own panache that could
really elevate it the acting is solid
throughout however in each character
feels like they're doing their best with
the material that they are given it's
just that the material as a whole is
pretty mundane so no I don't recommend
that you go and see Robin Hood this
weekend there is by far a better film
and creed to that I think deserves your
money more I've been predicting mr. bomb
since I saw the first trailer and
hopefully this is the final nail in the
coffin for a character that it's in sore
need of an arrow in the head so what are
your thoughts on Robin Hood do you
disagree with my opinion and what did
you like about the film comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and check out
my spoiler talk review of creed 2 which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is his channel for people who were
mad into movies so that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]